>> Pete: IT'S TIME FOR OUR
"SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT OR
RE-EXPLORE THE CULTURAL STORIES
OF THE DAY.
FOR THAT WE TURN TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
COUPLE TRAVEL STORIES OF CAUGHT
YOUR EYE.
>> PETE, YOU KNOW FROM YOUR
EXTENSIVE TRAVEL BUT IT'S HELL
OUT THERE.
I HAD TWO TRIPS DELAYED OR
CANCELED BY AS MANY AS 13 HOURS
IN ONE CASE.
I MISSED TWO SHOWS ON THIS
NETWORK.
I DEVELOPED RAYMOND'S RULES FOR
AIR TRAVEL.
DO NOT CLIP YOUR TOENAILS WHILE
ON BOARD AIRCRAFT.
ARMRESTS ARE TO KEEP YOU IN YOUR
SEAT SO ABIDE THE DIVIDE.
I HATE SPILLAGE.
I'M ADDING A FEW NEW RULES.
OWING TO A STORY THAT JUST
LANDED.
ON A RECENT SOUTHWEST FLIGHT,
PASSENGERS STARTED AIR DROPPING
VIA THEIR APPLE PHONES PICTURES
TO THE PILOT.
HE TOOK TO THE INTERCOM.
>> HERE'S THE DEAL.
IF THIS CONTINUES WHILE WE ARE
ON THE GROUND I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO PULL BACK TO THE GATE.
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO HAVE TO GET
OFF.
WE ARE GOING TO GET SECURITY
INVOLVED.
THIS VACATION IS GOING TO BE
RUINED.
WHATEVER THAT AIRDROP THING IS,
SENDING NAKED PICTURES.
>> IT BRINGS ME TO MY NEW RULE,
DO NOT SEND PORN TO THE PILOT.
LEAVE HIM ALONE.
>> Pete: IT SOUNDED LIKE DAD
IN THE FRONT SEAT.
KIDS, I WILL TURN THIS PLANE
AROUND IF YOU DO NOT BEHAVE.
THEY ARE GOING TO CABO.
THEY ARE HALFWAY THERE.
RAYMOND, WERE ANY OF YOUR DELAYS
-- LOST BAGGAGE HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE FOR THE PEOPLE.
IS THAT PART OF IT?
>> YOU BET.
THAT WAS NOT THE REASON FOR MY
DELAYS BUT IT DOES BRING ME TO
ANOTHER RULE, DO NOT CHECK
BAGGAGE ON CERTAIN AIRLINES.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION, THE WORST
AIRLINES FOR MISHANDLING
BAGGAGE, LOSING, DAMAGING, OR
STEALING YOUR BAGS, SINCE THE
TOP OF THE YEAR.
AMERICAN, MISHANDLED 450,000
BAGS FOLLOWED BY ALASKA AIRLINES
AND JETBLUE.
JUST STUFF THE CARRY-ONS.
FILL THEM UP AND DON'T LOOK BACK
BUT DON'T CHECK ANYTHING.
>> Pete: THEY DON'T REALLY
CHECK THEM AT SECURITY PURITY
USED TAFT WITH THEM AND THOSE
THINGS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE THE RIGHT SIZE.
THEY DON'T REALLY CHECK IT.
YOU GET TO THE GATE.
IT STAYS WITH YOU.
>> DON'T TELL EVERYBODY.
>> Pete: IT'S THE WAY TO GO.
HOW THEY NOT FIGURED OUT
SCANNING OF THE BAGS AND PUTTING
ON A PLANE QUITE YET?
WE WILL GET TO IT, ANOTHER
TOPIC.
APPRECIATE THOSE TIPS.
JOE BIDEN GAVE AN ANGRY SPEECH,
USE LIGHT, RIDDLED WITH FLUBS
YESTERDAY.
WATCH.
>> KEEP GUNS OUT -- TO KNOW WHAT
THE MEXICANS.
MEXICO WHICH HAS REAL PROBLEMS.
CAUSING US FOR PROBLEMS.
YOU KNOW THEIR BIGGEST COMPLAINT
IS CUSTOMER CAN'T WEEK TOP GUN
TRAFFIC ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER INTO MEXICO.
WE COULD SOLVE MORE GUN CRIMES
IF WE HAVE SOMEONE HEADING UP,
WHICH WE FINALLY DO.
WE THE PEOPLE, THAT'S OUR
CONSTITUTION, OUR DECLARATION.
WE THE PEOPLE.
>> HE IS UNSURE WHERE HE IS
ANYMORE.
TODAY JILL BIDEN, DR. BIDEN WAS
HOLDING A WHITE HOUSE MEETING ON
STRENGTHENING TEACHING, URGING
MORE MONEY FOR PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHERS WHICH YOU RECENTLY
WROTE ABOUT.
WE KNOW HOW MUCH GOOD THAT DOES.
THEN THE PRESIDENT WANDERED IN.
>> THESE PARTNERSHIPS WILL
CONTINUE TO EXIST.
I'M GOING TO STOP TALKING RIGHT
NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKING OF PARTNERS.
>> THAT'S A WRAP.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE ALL
LAUGHING ABOUT.
HE WANDERS IN AND WONDERS
WHATEVER SHE SAYS, I AGREE WITH
AND THEN LEFT.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
INCREASINGLY WE SEE THE
PRESIDENT BEING LED AROUND AT
TIMES LITERALLY BY THE WIFE AND
THE STAFF AND YOU JUST DON'T GET
THE SENSE THAT HE'S IN CHARGE OF
ANY OF THIS.
>> Pete: NO AND HE WOULDN'T BE
AWARE OF THE FACTOR BY SAYING
THAT HE'S REINFORCING THE
ALREADY PRECONCEIVED NOTION THAT
OTHER PEOPLE ARE HANDLING
THINGS.
WHATEVER SHE SAYS IS WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO.
HOW MANY TIMES A DAY DOES HE SAY
THAT IN RESPONSE?
>> GOOD THING THE EASTER BUNNY
WAS IN THE HALL TO PULL HIM OUT.
GOOD SAVE, EASTER BUNNY.
>> Pete: IT'S TRUE.
IN YOUR HOMETOWN OF NEW ORLEANS,
THERE'S AN EFFORT TO RECALL
MAYOR LATOYA CANTRELL.
WHAT'S DRIVING IT?
>> WE HAVE AN 83% INCREASE IN
MURDERS SINCE 2019.
NOW THE MAYOR'S OFFICE IS
RESPONDING.
HER KEYPAD MANAGER CLAIMS THE
RECALL EFFORT TO UNDERMINE AND
DISCREDIT THE BLACK WOMAN MAYORF
NEW ORLEANS FITS INTO A LONG
HISTORY OF TAKING AWAY OUR VOTE
AND VOICE.
REASON TO BELIEVE A CONSERVATIVE
D.C. FIRM HAS SIGNED ON TO LEAD
THE EFFORT.
MANY G.O.P. ORGANIZATIONS AND
CITY ARE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
SIGN THE PETITION.
THAT'S WHY FOX NEWS IS LEADING
THE PROPAGANDA CHARGE.
PETE, FOX NEWS MERELY REPORTED
THIS ONCE.
IT WAS ANNOUNCED.
SECONDLY THE TWO PEOPLE WHO
FILED THIS RECALL EFFORT AGAINST
CANTRELL ARE DEMOCRATS.
ONE OF THEM, EILEEN CARTER,
ACTUALLY WORKED FOR CANTRELL.
SHE TWEETED TODAY "WHY ARE YOU
LYING ABOUT YOUR RESIDENCE TO
YOUR RESIDENCE?"
THE OTHER FELLOW WHO SIGNED THE
RECALL EFFORT.
WE ARE BOTH BLACK AND IT'S NOT
RAISED ISSUE.
IT'S HER JOB PERFORMANCE ISSUE.
YOU SEE THIS KIND OF DOUBLE-TALK
IN THE ADMINISTRATION TRYING TO
COVER ITS TRACKS.
THESE ARE BLACK DEMOCRATS
LEADING THIS RECALL EFFORT
BECAUSE OF THE CRIME PRINCIPALLY
THE CRIME.
YOU KNOW.
>> Pete: YOU KNOW THAT CITY
BETTER THAN ANYBODY I KNOW.
IS THERE A REAL GRASSROOTS
FEELING THAT IT'S OUT OF
CONTROL?
>> ALL OVER THE CITY.
BLACK, WHITE, IN BETWEEN.
THERE IS ZERO MOTION AGAINST
WHAT THE MAYOR, THE STATE SHE
HAS CREATED IN THE CITY.